لذلك حصلنا على رسالة سكرتيرة
من جندي روسي
حصلنا عليها أولاً من قبل صحفي روسي مستقل ولديها
هنا مكتوب عليها مقولة أن
العدو يقسمنا مثل
بذور عباد الشمس في كل مكان حولنا
يخدعوننا ليس هناك حقيقة
في أي مكان تم إرسالنا إليه مثل الحملان للذبح
حتى موتنا الوشيك ،
رأينا جثثًا وأشخاصًا مشوهين بدون
أذرع وأرجل مع أحشائهم معلقة ،
ما هو رد فعلك تجاهك ، هل تعلم أننا
ننظر إلى هذا ، كما تعلم ، ترى
هذا في الطباعة  في
خط يد جندي دقيق بشكل لا يصدق وأنيق
جيدًا ، إنه حقًا ميدان قتل
هناك والعودة بشكل خاص ، نعلم أن
التقارير تشير إلى أنه مقابل كل
أوكراني أوكراني قتل أه
يوجد في أي مكان من خمسة إلى سبعة
جنود روس ، صحيح أن الأوكرانيين يذكرون
ذلك  الجنود الروس
يتكدسون مثل أه كما تعلمون مثل
جذوع الأشجار آه حبل من الخشب في
ساحة المعركة أن قادة فاجنر
يخبرون قواتهم إذا لم تقم
بالتقدم فسوف يطلقون النار عليك عندما
تعود ، أعني أن ما يحدث هو أمر غير أخلاقي حقًا
هناك وهو
وضع مروع والأوكرانيون
يقاتلون من أجل بلدهم من أجل
سيادتهم ، لذا انظروا أنهم
سيقاتلون من أجل
الفوز وهم يربحون ما يحدث لهذا
الجيل من أه من الرجال الروس أمر
مروع وأنا  أخشى أن
يزداد الأمر سوءًا لأنه في مرحلة ما
سيشن الأوكرانيون
هجومهم المضاد ربما في أبريل أو مايو
وسيؤدي ذلك حقًا إلى دفع
الروس إلى نقطة حيث سيضطرون
إلى تجنيد المزيد  أكثر من
أه من بلادهم